Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain episodes one and two
of a Thai television series called “Bad Genius.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The first scene shows us the final round of
a junior high school scrabble competition.
A girl named Lynn is competing against Sorrawis
from a rival school. Lynn’s father, Vit,
and the school's principal of a prestigious
school are in the audience watching the game.
The principal promises to admit Lynn to her school
with a full scholarship if she wins the match. Her
competitor Sorrawis seems to be struggling in the
last round so he deliberately drops an eraser.
His mentor picks it up and gives it back to him.
Lynn notices that the man changes the eraser with
one that has the answer written on it. She catches
Sorrawis cheating and quietly calls him out for
it, but doesn’t tell the judges. For her final
word, she writes “cheater” and wins the match.
The crowd applauds in cheers and Lynn
is given certificates of honor.
During dinner at night, her father Vit asks her
if she likes her new school. Lynn boasts about the
computers, rooms with ACs, and the library of the
school. She adds that her favorite place is the
music room that has a grand piano which she can
play during lunch. Vit inquires if she has made
any friends and Lynn awkwardly says she has.
One day while playing piano in school, Lynn
is approached by her classmate named Grace. She
asks Lynn’s help to practice a song for the school
play. Lynn plays the piano while Grace sings, but
they stop when Grace is off-key on certain parts.
She is sad because she might not get a role in the
play and claims that it is her dream to be in one.
Lynn then asks her to listen to the
keys carefully and go along with them.
After a little practice, Grace gets the keys
right and is overjoyed. Before Lynn leaves,
Grace asks her to wait for her outside the music
room so they can meet after her audition.
The audition goes great but Grace comes out of the
room with teary eyes. It turns out that according
to the new rule, students who want to be in the
school play must have a GPA above 3.25. When Grace
complains that she has never had a GPA that high,
Lynn offers to tutor her. For the next few days,
they study together in the library. Their math
teacher Sophon tutors students outside of school.
One day, Grace, who is also in his private class,
brings a sample question paper that Sophon has
provided. Lynn notices the questions are more
difficult than the ones he teaches in class
but practices them anyway.
A few weeks later, they are in their
midterm math exam. For the first few minutes,
Lynn answers all the questions with no difficulty
but then she notices most of the questions
are identical to the ones that Grace had.
It is clear to Lynn that Sophon has been providing
test questions to the students who pay him for
coaching outside school. She writes all the
answers on an eraser, puts it inside her shoe,
and kicks it back to Grace’s desk.
Grace gets the answers and copies them all down.
When the results are out, Grace is overjoyed
to get the highest marks she ever has.
But since the girls score the same, Sophon
is suspicious of them. He warns the girls to
be careful because if he finds them cheating, he
will not go easy on them. After he leaves, Grace
invites Lynn for dinner at her boyfriend Pat’s
house. In the evening, they go to meet Pat in a
lavish restaurant right next to his apartment.
He turns out to be a wealthy kid who is lazy
and gets bad grades. After he treats the girls
to dinner, he asks Lynn to help him in the exam
as she did with Grace. The girls are surprised
when Pat offers Lynn a lot of money to help him.
His father has promised to buy him a sports car
if he doesn’t fail, hence he desperately needs
her help. However, Lynn doesn’t want to risk
getting caught so she rejects the offer.
She returns home at night to her father Vit eating
noodles. Lynn asks him to be more careful with his
diet and goes to her room. A while later, she
hears him talk to someone on phone about a loan.
Lynn confronts him about this and finds out
that he has borrowed money from his brother
to pay for Lynn’s tuition. The principal promised
to provide her full scholarship if she wins the
scrabble contest but because of a budget issue,
Lynn and a guy from her school have to share the
scholarship. Meaning, they will still have to
pay half of the fee each semester. Lynn knows
that her father cannot afford such prices and
says she will transfer back to her old school,
but Vit insists she will get more opportunities
in this one. Now, to get a full scholarship,
Lynn will have to compete with the
other guy and prove she is better.
The following day at school, Lynn sees a little
kid trying hard to get a balloon on the ceiling.
She tries to help him but cannot reach it. Just
then, a guy named Bank arrives there and helps
them. The kid calls them a nice couple making
the two fluster. After the kid walks away,
Lynn introduces herself and finds out
Bank is actually the guy she is sharing
her scholarship with. She asks him if they
can still be friends but Bank rejects her
saying that they are competitors. In the following
scene, Lynn is back at Pit’s apartment building.
To pay for her father’s loans and her tuition fee,
she finally agrees to help him and Grace cheat
in the exam. Her condition is that the couple
will only get three-fourths of the answers so
their teacher won’t suspect them. Pit accepts the
deal. The following scene is their final exam of
the first semester and Lynn has to help both Grace
and Pit alongside completing the test herself.
Like earlier, she starts writing on an eraser
but stops when Sophon walks towards her.
He keeps an eye on her throughout the exam and
eventually notices her writing on the eraser. The
man snatches the eraser and is surprised to see
“You’re slipping exam papers to students” written
on it. He realizes she knows his secret and tries
to reason with her but Lynn hands him her answer
sheet and walks out of the classroom. Sophon
asks the others to continue and goes behind Lynn.
Lynn remains adamant about telling the principal
as Sophon tries to convince her otherwise.
He even threatens to tell the principal
she let Grace cheat from her paper,
but Lynn backfires saying that Grace got good
grades because of his tuition classes. As she
walks away, Sophon notices her hand is inside
her pocket and asks her if she is recording their
conversation. When she brings her phone out, it is
revealed she has been on a call with the principal
this whole time. A distressed Sophon heads back
to the classroom as the students get out.
Grace and Pit thank Lynn as everything
went according to their plan. It turns
out that they had planned the whole scenario
beforehand. Because of Sophon’s tuition papers,
Lynn could complete her paper in just a few
minutes. She also marked the answers on her
question paper and asked Grace to exchange
it with hers when she distracts Sophon.
After that, Grace wrote the answers on an eraser
and gave them to Pit, and all three of them did
great in the exam. Moreover, Lynn had changed
Pit’s name on her phone to the Principal’s.
That way, she wouldn’t get Sophon kicked out but
still intimidate him. However, later at night,
she gets numerous messages on a group chat saying
that Sophon has been fired from the school. Lynn
rushes to Pit’s apartment again and asks him
how did the principal know. Pit replies that
he had recorded the phone call and sent it to
the principal because he believes Sophon could
create trouble for them in the future. Lynn isn’t
happy about the move but dismisses the matter.
The next day at school, she again meets the
same kid and finds out he is Sophon’s son
who has been kicked out of the school
because of his father’s deeds. Lynn watches
them go down the elevator in guilt.
In the following scene, we are taken to
Bank’s laundry shop. He lives with his single
mother who is obsessed with lottery tickets.
She has severe back problems but because of their
financial condition, they cannot afford to get
it treated. Later in school, Bank and Lynn are
called by the principal because she wants them
to take part in a TV show quiz competition. Both
of them are not willing to partner up but the
principal convinces them by declaring that this
competition will decide who is going to get the
next term scholarship among the two. Hence, even
if they are partnering, the one who gives the most
answer will get the scholarship. The very next
day, they are on the set of the reality show.
The quiz starts and Bank gives the first right
answer followed by Lynn. The duo leads by two
points but is soon overtaken when Bank hastily
says the wrong answer. Lynn suggests he think and
discuss with her before throwing random answers.
If they go against each other, they might lose
the quiz, so, for the last question, they discuss
the answer. The other team answers first but gets
their answer wrong. At last, Lynn cites the right
one and wins the competition. The following day,
they are at the principal’s office where she
tells them that Lynn has won a full scholarship.
She asks Bank to apply for a scholarship
again next semester and dismisses them.
After the meeting, Lynn tries to comfort Bank but
he ignores her. Later, we see him take his mother
to a government hospital where they have to wait
for hours for her turn. He also tells her that he
didn’t get the scholarship. But the mother quickly
hides her disappointment and assures him she will
collect the money before the next semester.
One day at school, Pit calls Lynn into the
computer lab and asks her if she will stop
helping him cheat now that she doesn’t have
to pay for tuition. He laughs at her when the
girl says she doesn’t need his money anymore.
According to Pit, the school will still take
fees for extracurricular activities that
she probably doesn’t know about. Lynn doesn’t
react but doubts he might be telling the truth.
So, when she returns home, she goes through
her father’s drawer and sees that he has paid
the school a total of two hundred thousand bhat
as a “maintenance fee”, This makes her realize
that “full scholarship” is just a publicity stunt
for the school and they still make money from all
their students. Lynn quickly calls Pit and asks if
there are more people willing to pay her like him.
The following day, Pit arranges a meeting with
Lynn, Grace, and his rich friends who need Lynn’s
help. She asks all of them for thirty thousand
bhat to help them cheat for one semester. They
will have to pay Pit who will, in turn, give the
money to Lynn so there is no proof of payment.
But since there are many people, passing
answers on erasers would be too risky.
Hence, Lynn comes out with another plan. She
remembers there is a clock in the front wall
that is visible to everyone. She declares that the
minute hand on the wall is the number of question
they are in. Similarly, since the questions are
multiple-choice, they will have four options.
The second hand on the clock will be the answer.
So, if the answer is number A, Lynn will raise her
hand when the second-hand reaches 1, if the answer
is B, she will raise her hand when it reaches 2.
The exam will be held for two hours and there
will be sixty questions in total which means
Lynn will have to complete hers in an hour
and dedicate the next hour to help the others.
The test goes as they had planned.
But midway, Bank, who is sitting right
next to Lynn, asks her to stop moving so much
because he cannot concentrate. Suddenly, he drops
a piece of paper on the floor that the teacher
sees. She takes the paper from him believing
it is a cheat, but it turns out to be the list
of customers’ addresses from his laundry.
She then urges him to bring everything out
of his pockets but a tired Bank accidentally
pukes on his paper. Everyone in the class
laughs at him as he rushes to the washroom.
In the evening, Lynn goes to Bank’s home telling
him that she doesn’t need the scholarship anymore
so she is giving it back to him. A surprised
Bank asks her why but Lynn hides the fact that
she earned enough money from helping her friends
cheat. Instead, she says that her father won the
lottery. Bank happily offers to do her laundry
for free as a thank you gift. He then tags along
to take her home by bus. The episode ends as
he says he wants to be friends with Lynn.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the
channel out. Thanks for watching.